in the last video we saw that if you
wanted to take I don't know a plus B to
the nth power and if n is larger than
really - but really especially larger
than three it is very tedious to
multiply it out essentially using the
distributive property or you know kind
of doing polynomial multiplication or
foil or however you learned it it is
extremely extremely tedious and then we
learned the binomial theorem which said
this that that is equal to the sum the
sum from k is equal to 0 to n of n
choose k right where that was you know
what we learned in combinatorics is as
the binomial coefficient and that's why
it's called the binomial coefficient
because it's actually the coefficients
of the binomial theorem of X to the N
minus K of so I keep writing X let me
undo that edit undo edit undo oh it's
taking too long now let me just no no
that's not what I wanted to do let me
erase it I'm okay
keep writing X it could be an X but then
this would have to be an X here as well
maybe I should do that of a to the N
minus K times B to the K so each term
you know the N stays constant but each
term you start at K equals 0 and you
keep incrementing up and we did an
example to solve a plus B to the fourth
power in the previous video and as you
saw that was tedious but less tedious
that actually multiplying it out and you
know if you get really fast at computing
you know n choose K for different ends
in cave it could be reasonably fast so
what I want to do is I'm going to show
you a slightly faster method than what
we just did kind of a faster way to
compute the binomial coefficients and
then after that I'm going to show you a
super fast way that sort of memorizing
the coefficients which I actually know
some people who've done that is a pretty
amazing way to essentially multiply out
anybody
binomial so what's what's my pseudo fast
way of doing it
well I hinted in the last in the last
presentation that we that those
coefficients were actually terms of a
Pascal triangle so what's a Pascal
triangle so if we start off with a 1 and
then you just go actually I'm gonna do
it in the well yeah let me do it right
here and then actually let me start with
two ones and what you do is you take the
sum of both of these so that's two and
then you bring down a 1 to the left on
the right hand side and notice these are
the coefficients of a plus B squared
right and these are the coefficients of
a plus B you could say a plus B to the 1
right 1 a plus 1 B this is a squared 1
ace so you could rewrite you know a plus
B squared is 1
a squared plus 2 a B plus 1 B squared so
this is a coat these are the
coefficients of a plus B squared and let
me arbitrarily switch colors and so 1
plus 2 is 3 2 plus 1 is 3 bring down the
1 bring down the 1 and now we have the
coefficients for a plus B to the third
which we computed in the that was the
very first thing we did we actually
multiply it out and we we just know the
pattern the first coefficient is 1 so
it's 1 a to the third B to the 0 so we
don't have to write the B plus 3 we just
decrement this exponent 1 3 a squared B
plus 3 a B squared and then plus 1 a to
the 0 which is just 1 B cubed so that
was pretty fast and we could keep going
down the Pascal triangle so let's let's
do the next one so we can bring down a 1
1 plus 3 is 4 3 plus 3 is 6 and I this
is me this I mean that just very simply
you can actually generate binomial
coefficients without having to compute
them very simple I guess you could call
it an algorithm
or drawing for one and it's symmetric
just as you would expect it right
because you could easily switch be an a
a plus B is the same thing as B plus a
so you should essentially get the same
answer and so we just very quickly we
figured out the binomial coefficients
for a plus B to the fourth which was a
lot faster than we did in the last
example right a plus B to the fourth so
then we you know we I think you get the
point but so it's 1 let me write in a
different color one a to the fourth B to
the 0 plus 4 a cubed B squared a B B to
the 1 plus 6 a squared B squared which
makes sense that you know this is the
middle number and they both an A and B
have the same exponent at this point and
then plus 4a we decrement it b cubed
plus B to the 4th one B to the 4th right
a to the 0 so that's why we didn't write
there so 1 B to the 4th all right so
once and and that was very fast compared
to what we had to do at the end of the
last video and then we could just keep
going you know 4 5 so 1 1 plus 4 is 5 4
plus 6 is 10 6 plus 4 is 10 4 plus 1 is
5
bring down the 1 so these are the these
are the coefficients for the expansion
of a plus B to the fifth power and so
this is a reasonably fast way of doing
it although it can get what it'll take a
lot of space and it it it can work
reasonably well you know for up to a
power of I don't know 8 or 9 or 10 even
then it starts to get pretty big and
cumbersome but you know 4 powers up to 7
or 8 or 9 you could do this you could
draw it out really fast and do this and
it's probably faster than actually
computing each of the binomial
coefficients although you might be
pretty fast at you know computing n
choose K which you don't have to do this
so with that out of the way let me show
you an even faster way of doing it short
of memorizing it and this will allow you
to really calculate a plus B to the nth
you know to the 20th power almost in
your head depending on how good you are
at arithmetic in your head
so here is the trick and now and I
encourage you to experiment for why it
works but it does work and I mean and
it's not even a trick it's just I mean
you know in this this this Pascal's
triangle isn't even a trick Pascal's
triangle is just an alternative way to
generate binomial coefficients and what
I'm about to show you is just another
way of essentially generating the
binomial coefficients although it's
probably a faster way to compute them
and it's good project for you to think
about why this works so I'm just going
to start with a very concrete example
instead of a plus B let me just do X
plus y just because you might see the
binomial the binomial theorem written
that way so let's say X plus y to the
tenth power this would take me all day
if I was at to actually multiply it out
it would be it would take me probably
probably 20 to 30 minutes without making
careless mistakes to actually figure out
all the binomial coefficients maybe not
that long but it would take me a while
and to draw Pascal's triangle would fill
up a whole page and I'd still probably
make a careless mistake so how can I do
this so what you do is so one thing you
know that this is going to have this is
going to have eleven terms right because
you're going to start with X to the
tenth Y to the zero and you're going to
go all the way to Y to the tenth right
so if you start at zero and you go to
ten that's eleven terms so this has
eleven terms what I want you to do is
just write down the first just the
numbers you know you can almost count
the terms you don't have to go all the
way to 11 and I'll show you but let's
actually let's write all the way to 11
so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 just squeeze
it in and then you'll see you don't
actually don't have to go all the way de
Levin you could probably just stop at 6
so here's the trick we know that the
first term is going to be X to the 10th
right we know that X to the 10th and
actually I mean we know that it's going
to be X to the 10th the second term is
going to be X to the ninth and it's
going to be X to the 8th it's going to
be X to the seventh it's get a little
tedious X to the sixth X to the fifth X
to the fourth
X to the third X squared X and then
there's going to be note this is going
to be X to the zero or just one let me
just do the the the Y's so this was this
was X to the tenth there's that's not
that's not bright enough this color so
there's this is Y to the 0 so we don't
have to write it there but then we have
a y y to the first y squared Y the third
Y to the fourth Y to the fifth which
makes sense this is the middle term y to
the sixth Y to the 7th Y to the 8th Y to
the ninth and I don't want you to get
confused each of these is a separate
term I don't want you to think I'm
multiplying them all right and then we
just have to figure out the coefficients
on each of these terms that those are
divider lines that I attempted to draw I
wasn't trying to confuse you more
I just wanted to because they seem to be
running together each of the terms that
I'm writing but I think you know what
I'm doing
so now we have to figure out the
coefficients and then this is this is
the neat part so we know that the
coefficient on the first term let me
draw a dividing line here and here the
coefficient of the first term is always
1 right so the coefficients one so the
coefficient on the second term is going
to be the exponent on the first term
times its coefficient so ten times one
divided by the term that it is so it's
going to be ten times 110 times one
divided by one so it's going to be ten
the third terms coefficient is going to
be the exponent on the X right so it's
nine times its coefficient which is ten
so it's going to be nine times 10
divided by the term it is so nine
there's going to be nine times its
coefficient ten divided by two
so what's nine times ten that's 40 it's
a 90 divided by two which is 45 and you
keep going the fourth term is going to
be the third terms exponent so it's
going to be eight times let me write
this down in a different color it's
going to be eight right eight times its
code
efficient times 45 divided by which term
it is so it's the third term divided by
three well that's just 8 times 15 and
we'll see that's 80 plus 40 so that's
equal to 120 so that is the fourth term
and so then let me just draw these
dividers I know it's getting a little
complicated and I'm writing it all out
like this but if you practice this
enough you can actually just write it
straight out and so the fifth term what
is the fifth term will you take the
exponent on the X so seven seven times
the fourth terms coefficient times 120
divided by 4 right divided by the
previous term by four well that's just
seven times 30 which equals to 10 that's
the fifth coefficient what's the sixth
coefficient well it's six it's six times
so you know the exponent on the X times
to ten times its coefficient times the
fifth terms coefficient divided by five
for the fifth term well 5 goes into 210
how many times 42 times right so it's 6
times 42 that's 240 plus 12 is 252 right
252 and then once you're at the middle
point right X the sixth term is the
middle term you'll see that you know you
you start going back the other way and
we learn one from the Pascal's triangle
or even the definition of the binomial
theorem that that the coefficients are
symmetric so we know that the next one
is going to be the same this was the
middle one right so we know the next
one's going to be 210 it's going to be
210 and you could you could calculate it
using the same system I'm just this is
just a quick way of doing it this one's
going to be 120 this one's going to be
45 and this one this one is going to be
the 10th co fifth this is going to be 10
and then of course the last coefficient
is just 1 1 y to the tenth power so so
if I were to write this out the answer
is and if you practice this you'll find
that you can do it quite fast
it's X to the tenth X to the tenth plus
ten X to the ninth y plus 45 X to the
eighth I'm sorry X to the eighth Y
squared plus 120 X to the 7th Y to the
third plus two 10 X to the sixth Y to
the fourth plus 252 already the middle
term X to the fifth Y to the fifth plus
two 10 X to the fourth Y to the six I'm
running out of space but you can you can
hopefully extrapolate what I'm doing and
it makes sense to you and hopefully you
have an appreciation that if you
actually have to multiply out X plus y
to the tenth it would have taken you all
day maybe I'll do one more video with a
with a smaller example to show you that
it's a little less complicated when you
do say X plus y to the sixth power see
you soon